ils sont en retraite ils sont obligés à
une obligation de réserve qui devrait
jamais quitter leur esprit puis il
s'agit d'anciens militaires de
militaires à la retraite qui ont tout à
fait le droit de s'exprimer
[Musique]
alors j'entends e militaire factieux
reprises et militaire d'alger qui
voulaient déferlé sur la république
fascisme
on est on nage en plein délire cette
inversion des valeurs dans notre système
médiatique est proprement insupportable
[Musique]
c'est tellement grossier
c'est tellement gros chez les militaires
ne peuvent pas s'engager en politique
même si son citoyen madame le pen leur
tend la main pour des raisons évidentes
voilà elle joue changeux elle joue son
jeu c'est grave c'est dangereux et ce
qu'a rappelé marine le pen c'est qu'elle
appelle justement ces militaires et ses
généraux nous les appelons à rejoindre
nos rangs pour une bataille électorale
une bataille démocratique qui n'a rien à
voir avec un putsch
[Musique]